there is a lawyer named Lanny Davis who
is very much hated by the American right
wing and he's hated not only because
he's a Democrat but because he's also a
close friend of Bill and Hillary
Clinton's and he's also a Democratic
strategist and public relations
consultant a well known one who has
worked for a number of prominent
Democrats he has now been hired by note
the use of the word former former Trump
personal attorney Michael Cohen this is
fascinating and to catch you up on
Michael Cohen Cohen was Trump's personal
lawyer he was involved in the hundred
and thirty thousand dollar payoff to
stormy Daniels he's in big trouble his
office condo and home and hotel room
rather were raided by investigators his
lawyers abandoned him multiple reports
that he's likely going to flip and
inform on Donald Trump and as I've said
before if anybody has dirt on Trump real
dirt on Trump its Michael Cohen and
Donald Trump and the Trump
administration increasingly pretending
they barely even remember who Cohen was
Lanny Davis was asked why he's joining
the legal team for Michael Cohen he said
that when he heard Cohen say recently on
ABC that his allegiance is to his family
and to his country not to Donald Trump
Lanny Davis was convinced that this was
somebody that he felt comfortable or was
interested in working with Lanny Davis
notably wrote a book claiming that the
election was stolen from Hillary Clinton
and he is now representing the one guy
the one guy who is most likely to have
evidence if that evidence exists if it
is true that the election was stolen
from Hillary Clinton that guy is Michael
Cohen so a few different things to think
about number one how in trouble is Cohen
at this point
what does Cohen know at this point
Michael Cohen is not commenting on the
higher Cohen's other lawyer guy Petrillo
also not commenting on the higher the
one possible downside loot to this that
I want to hear from the audience about
is does this
make it easier for the right to cast
Cohen as a guy seeking revenge rather
than justice because he goes and he
hires prominent Clinton friend Lanny
Davis that's my question for you let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
fruit or futur is a social forecasting
game where players come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events you open up the game on
your phone or web browser you'll see a
whole range of forecasts covering topics
across the board politics sports so much
more you wager on predictions about real
world events using food tours in game
fake currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and you
can sign up now at fruit or calm and
start making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers and
right now on foote or you can win cash
prizes for correct predictions about the
World Cup check it out at fut you you
are calm